AGRICULTURE MINISTER ABRUPTLY
RESIGNING.
WHEN BIDEN, JENNIFER GRANHOLM
AND CO. SAY WE ARE TRANSITIONIN
TO A CLEANER FUTURE, WHAT
THEY'RE REALLY SAYING IS THEY
HAVE ADDED AMERICA'S NAME TO A
GROWING GLOBAL SUICIDE PACT RAT
JOINING ME NOW IS TUCKER CARLSO
HOST OF TUCKER CARLSON TONIGHT
AND TUCKER CARLSON ORIGINALS ON
FOX NATION.
THE CULT OF CONFUSION IS
AVAILABLE NOW FOR A TUCKER,
WE'RE GOING.
>> YOU'RE NEXT SERIES AND JUST
MOMENT.
THESE AREN'T ISOLATED INCIDENTS.
IT'S EASY TO REPORT ON THEM AND
SUCH FOR THIS IS HAPPENING IN
COLORADO, IN BRITAIN, IN FRANCE
BUT THIS IS GLOBAL CONSENSUS
BUILDING THAT WE HAVE TO LOWER
EVERYBODY'S CONTENTION IN THE
STANDARD OF LIVING.
YOU DON'T HAVE CIVILIZATION
WITHOUT IT.
CIVILIZATIONS GROW AND THEY
CONTRACT AND WITHOUT IT.
THEY GET CONTROL OF THE ENERGY.
TO SOMEONE, THAT PERSON CONTROLS
.
SO ENERGY IS CONTROLLED, WE'VE
HAD THE ENERGY FOR SO LONG WE
WERE ENERGY INDEPENDENT ABOUT 1
MINUTES AGO.
PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW
PRESSING THIS IS AND HOW CLOSE
WE ARE TO BEING UNDER CLEAT
COMPLETE AND TOTAL CONTROL.
IT'S TO LIMIT HOW FAR PEOPLE
COULD TRAVEL, MAYBE SOMEDAY
BATTERIES WILL BE LONGER MILEAG
BANDS AND SO FORTH, BUT RIGHT
NOW FOR MOST ELECTRIC CARS, YOU
CAN TRAVEL 250-350 MILES ON ONE
FULL CHARGE.
THAT LIMITS HOW FAR PEOPLE CAN
GO.
THAT IN AND OF ITSELF IS A
LIMITATION ON THE FREEDOM OF
MOVEMENT WHICH FRANKLY WEREN'T
GUARANTEED IN OUR FOUNDING
DOCUMENTS FRAID NOT ANYMORE
APPARENTLY BRETT.
>> IT'S AN ATTACK ON THE
INDIVIDUAL ECONOMY.
YOU CAN ONLY BE DENIED ACCESS I
CALIFORNIA.
THE GRID DOESN'T WORK NOW.
KNOW, CHANGING OUTS, MAKING
ILLEGAL DAY GASOLINE ENGINE THE
SIGNAL BIGGEST CHANGE AND THE
WAY AMERICANS WILL LIVE IN OUR
LIFETIMES.
THERE IS NO BIGGER CHANGE THAN
THIS.
BY THE WAY, ELECTRIC VEHICLES
ARE TERRIBLE FOR THE ENVIRONMEN
FRAID I'M NOT TALKING ABOUT
CARBON EMISSIONS BY THE AMOUNT
OF MINING REQUIRED TO GET
ELECTRIC VEHICLES FAR OUTSTRIPS
WHAT YOU NEED TO BE A BIG CHEVY
TAHOE.
IT'S ONLY ABOUT CONTROL.
IT'S CALLED TRANSGRESSIVE, THE
CULT OF CONFUSION.
AND WANT TO SHOW EVERYBODY AS
SNEAK PEAK.
>> THEY BECAUSE THEY MAKE EMPTY
PROMISES TO WOUNDED PEOPLE.
>> IT MAKES YOU COOLER.
>> IT'S HARDER AND SMARTER THAN
EVERYONE ELSE.
>> THE PROMISE IS VERY
STRAIGHTFORWARD.
ALL YOUR PROBLEMS CAN BE SOLVED
BY CHANGING HER BODY.
THIS IS PARTICULARLY APPEALING
TO LAST TEENAGERS IN THE
EVANGELIST SPREADING BACK ARE O
TIK TOK.
>> GIRLS GO ONLINE AND THEY
WATCH THESE VIDEOS NOW ON TIK
TOK, THEY ARE WELL PRODUCED AND
FUN TO WATCH THERE IS PROMISE
THAT IF YOU JUST START A COURSE
EVERYTHING IS GOING TO GET A LO
BETTER.
YOUR ANXIETY WILL GET UNDER
CONTROL.
YOUR DEPRESSION, YOU'RE GOING T
FEEL GREAT, AND THESE GIRLS OUR
IN A LOT OF REAL PLAINT PAIN AN
LOOKING FOR A SOLUTION.
>> TUCKER, THIS IS AN ISSUE YOU
AND I AS PARENTS IN AMERICANS
SHARE SOME LEVEL OF PASSION IN
DEEP CONCERN ABOUT.
WHAT DID YOU LEARN NEW WAY AND
YOU ARE MAKING THIS?
>> THAT CHILDREN ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ARE BEING SEXUALLY
MUTILATED AND THAT NONE OF US
ARE SAYING ANYTHING ABOUT IT
BECAUSE WE'RE SO INTIMIDATED BY
THE AGGRESSION IN THE LUNACY OF
THE ADVOCATES OF THIS IN THE
ENTIRE AMERICAN MEDIA AND
UNFORTUNATELY EVERY INSTITUTION
INTO AMERICAN LIFE HAS BEEN
BULLIED INTO SHUTTING UP AS
CHILDREN AREN'T MUTILATED.
IT'S BEYOND BELIEF IT'S ACTUALL
HAPPENING.
I THINK ANYONE RUNNING FOR
OFFICE OR HOLDING OFFICE HAS
MORAL TO PUNISH PEOPLE WHO ARE
DOING IT.
NO DOCTOR SHOULD BE ALLOWED TO
DO THIS EVER.
IN THOSE DOCTORS SHOULD BE
CHARMED FOR THE CRIMES THEY ARE
COMMITTING.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT IS
HAPPENING, IT JUST TAKE A LOOK
AT THAT.
THERE IS NO DEFENDING IT.
>> THEY GO FOR THIS
TRANSFORMATIVE SURGERIES.
YOU POINTED THIS OUT.
THE LEVEL OF SUICIDE POST
PUBERTY, EARS INTO THEIR QUOTE
TRANSITION, THAT DOESN'T GET
DISCUSSED AT ALL.
AT ALL.
CAKE IT NONE OF THE DETAILS GET
DISCUSSED.
A LOT OF IT WE COULDN'T PUT ON
TELEVISION BECAUSE THEY ARE TOO
HORRIFYING.
IT IS INCREASED THOUSANDS OF
PERCENT IN THE LAST TWO YEARS,
NO.
THIS IS THE PRODUCT OF A
SUSTAINED PROPAGANDA CAMPAIGN O
SOCIAL MEDIA TO LURE CHILDREN
INTO THIS AND THEN TO STERILIZE
AND SEXUALLY MUTILATED THEM.
WHY ARE WE POINTING OUT THIS?
>> I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR DOIN
THIS.
I WANT EVERYONE TO BE SURE TO
CATCH THIS SERIES CALLED
TRANSGRESSIVE, THE CULT OF
CONFUSION.
TUCKER COME UP MOST IMPORTANTLY
THANK YOU FOR STAYING UP WITH US
.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
>> I'M HONORED TO BE HERE.
>> I DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT OUT
LIKE YOU GO TO BED AT 9:00
O'CLOCK EVERY NIGHT, BUT
IT'S A LITTLE LATE.
AND YOU'RE AT LEAST